sell less than your ability to sell
and i think that's the dance that most
people mess up and so if i had to
consolidate it into two words let's give
more
and if you give more than you take the
marketplace will always reward you but
most people their messaging is just you
know give take
give take
give take whereas rather than like the
true like give give give
and my opinion is give give give give
give keep going and eventually you just
start getting you don't even have to ask
you just start getting and the people
that you specifically select be your
customers will get outsized returns
they'll rave about you more people will
demand what you want and by doing that
you never have to keep generating demand
you will always have more demand than
you want and that demand will continue
to multiply that's just something that i
have lived through um
and i think that if that became real for
more people
more people would become zillionaires
but it requires the the big p word which
is patience and most people don't